تسببت موجه امطار شديده في اغراق عده
احياء في العاصمه بغداد ونقلت وسائل
الاعلام عراقيه مقاطع فيديو لاحياء
العاصمه وقد امتلات شوارعها وازقتها
وساحتها العامه بمياه الامطار التي هطلت
في غزاله فجر اليوم
هو من بغداد مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراد في
العربيه منتظر الرشيد اهلا بكم منتظر
وضعنا في صوره المشهد في بغداد والمناطق
المتضرره بسبب هذه الامطار
يعني الامطار التي هطلت طبعا بكميات كبيره
في عدد من المحافظات طبعا نتحدث هنا عن
محافظه دياله وصولا الى محافظه واسط ميسان
في الجنوب الشرقي وايضا شرق البلاد اضافه
الى البصره في اقصى الجنوب العراقي وسورا
الى محافظه الديوانيه همم على الحدود
الجنوبيه الغربيه للبلاد اضافه الى
العاصمه العراقيه كل هذه المحافظات شهدت
هطولا كبيرا لكميات كبيره من الامطار فجر
اليوم همم ارتفاع منسوب المياه وصل في بعض
المناطق الى اكثر من واحد 31 سنتيمترا
ماده الى غرق بعض الاحياء في العاصمه
بغداد رغم الجهود الكبيره التي بذلتها
امانه العاصمه همم والتي تمكنت من خلالها
من سحب كميات كبيره من المياه من 90%
تقريبا من احياء العاصمه بغداد لكن هذا
الحي الذي يتواجد فيه وهو من احياء جنوب
العاصمه وبغداد وايضا بعض الاحياء الاخرى
كميات كبيره من وتجمعت فيها لم تتمكن الى
الان همم امانه العاصمه بغداد من سحب هذه
المياه اضافه الى غرق ايضا بعض احياء شرق
العاصمه بغداد والتي عاده ما تشهد همم
غرقا همم
بمياه الامطار مع كل هطونا لكميات كبيره
من الامطار وهذا خلال السنوات ايضا
الماضيه كان واضحا لكن نتحدث اليوم ونحن
هنا من داخل احد هذه الاحياء الحركه صعبه
جدا هناك بعض السيارات توقفت نتيجه ارتفاع
منسوب المياه كما تشاهدون الان هذه همم
ان هناك ايضا اصابات او حاله وفاه حدثت
بسبب هذه الامطار ايضا
يعني عاده ما تحدث هناك حالات وفاه بسبب
اما ااه تماس الكهربائي نتيجه هطول
الامطار
وايضا هناك ايضا غرق لبعض المؤسسات
الحكوميه في بعض المناطق نتحدثنا عن بعض
المراكز الصحيه المستشفيات المؤسسات
الخدميه شهدت همم
امطارا غزيره البلاد وبالتالي ايضا همم
غمرتها المياه ايضا تسببت هذه الامطار
بحدوث حرائق وهذا غريب ايضا في بعض
الاحياء في بعض الاسواق المراكز التجاريه
بعض المؤسسات ايضا الخدميه شهدت حرائق في
انحاء متفرقه طبعا من البلاد رغم طول هذه
الامطار بالتالي هناك حالات وفاه احدى
حالات الوفاه طالت مسؤولا في وزاره
التربيه العراقيه ايضا صباح هذا اليوم على
خلفيه هطول هذه الامطار بالتالي نحن امام
كميات كبيره في وبتن قصيره جدا من الامطار
هطلت ادت الى ما تشاهدونه الان في العاصمه
بغداد اضافه الى سيول اشتاحت الكثير من
الاراضي الزراعيه شرق البلاد